good evening and welcome to the Avena
report breaking news
Acacio burger has grown a beard more on
that story later a news groundbreaking
invention has been created by the
revolutionary company jawbone
recently they've announced the release
of a new product called doopy doopy is a
wristband that tracks data using sensors
now we're cutting line to our technology
correspondent Steve who is with the lead
scientist of jawbone
professor Park at jawbone headquarters
in New Zealand Thank You Vishnu I'm here
live professor Park
so tell me about your magnificent
weights
well upwards brought into creation and
designed specifically to be integrated
into everyone's lives if its primary aim
is to help the user become health
literate by tracking their every
movement in a systematic approach to
tell us more about this wondrous more
inspiring invention well it tracks the
sleeping patterns which includes the
light versus deep sleep and waking
moments intelligently 24/7 furthermore
he chats every physical movement
including distance covered and calories
consumed by an individual and hence an
individual's overall activity intensity
it gives you an ID alert that reminds
you to move if you have been inactive
for too long and also a smart alarm to
wake you up if both after cow enough
which is around twenty four point five
minutes finally fascinating as Professor
Park has shown us that Yuki is amazing
and an extremely intriguing item that I
would love to
back to you it's neat it's on Oh
all right it's on okay joining us today
is our technique the is Shrek take mr.
Walker hi I'm mr. Tecna savatya and I'm
here to tell you about the faults and
shortcomings of this thing this is these
include it's costing price of one
hundred and fifty dollars just for a
bracelet which individuals may find
expensive there's also the privacy issue
if the bracelet is lost or stolen then
people can find out what you do in your
daily activities god
please take this blue this is your way
please to our health correspondent Steve
who's currently with health experts and
health King so Ann what are your healthy
thoughts on this healthy product this
neutral buying gadget sounds a lot more
intense than it actually is the idea
behind this is that a small wristband
will calculate every movement and
nutritional intake that occurs with your
daily life however the way it works is
far more subtle than that
diabetes is becoming a more frequent
problem in this model product back to
you healthy Vishnu and those viewers who
should be eating health
Thanks
healthy Steve we now have an exclusive
interview with top fashion designer -
new fashion Kumar sorry
That's not me tell us about your
thoughts without this product
that bracelet is not suited to be I mean
the color scheme does not even suit
passcode colors like a hello you coward
outside furthermore buying this product
bad
I mean hashtag ugly our girl this
product is simply hideous and anyone
with an ounce of fashion should not work
unless they want to look ugly um I'll
have to stop you there we're running out
of time
you need next week for our breaking into
you with cush rangoon from us and the
team at Avena report good night